you look like you're supposed to be a
thug but the glasses that you read books
what do you do for a living bro
that's a fake job it didn't mean
anything the guy just said two words and
he thinks I'm gonna be like oh that's
real cool what's a service advisor
just as fake as what you said before to
be honest with you most jobs are fake
I've realized this always
are like get a real job you'll get a
real job what is an
automotive service advisor that's a
mechanic he said no like I'm an
he said don't that sound exactly like
that hey man you need new brakes that's
automotive service advisor tell me what
you think is the difference
what do you do
you just looking from afar you just
doing like this
oh this probably comes home after work
like oh babe I'm so tired he didn't do
nothing he
didn't come home no oil on his shirt
ever
I told you about that for months